was so jaw-dropping that it all really
happened that it felt important to try
to tell the story as authentically as we
could and you know you need to have
certain plot points because he did do
these things but you don't need to
embellish them well looks like Netflix's
monster may not be as authentic as we
think
Ann e Schwartz a former crime reporter
who first broke the story of Jeffrey
Dahmer's gruesome murders in 1991 is
calling out the show and pointing out
what she says they got wrong
I really think we're different
the critically acclaimed Evan peters-led
series well and says they're dramatizing
the story to make it entertaining
there's something was coming to me
uh-huh and worked for the Milwaukee
Journal at the time of Dahmer's arrest
she says the show does not bear a great
deal of resemblance to the facts of the
case here's why in an interview with the
independent and opens up about the smell
referenced multiple times throughout the
show what is the smell according to Ann
it's actually not what it seems quote I
was a crime reporter for five years so I
know what it smells like when you walk
into a building with a dead body or a
decomposing body that was not that this
was a very chemical smell
smell is worse than ever
is it in the series Niecy Nash plays
Glenda Cleveland the neighbor who first
alerted police of Dahmer's suspicious
Behavior to tell this story specifically
through Glenda's lens as it had never
been done before so that comes with a
lot of responsibility because you want
to make sure you get it right but M
points out there are some inaccuracies
here too
I know hey Jeff sorry to bother you but
there's a smell coming from your
apartment the series features many
hallway encounters between Dahmer and
his neighbor but Anne claims none of
that ever happened in fact ancest Glenda
didn't live across the hall she actually
lived in a completely separate building
quote I had trouble with buy-in because
I knew that was not accurate but people
are not watching it that way they're
watching it for entertainment
9-1-1 hello this is Glenda Cleveland can
you send an officer to the Oxford
Apartments
well I I think it's a fight going on
next door and somebody somebody is
either being hurt or killed over the
course of his murders Dahmer killed 17
victims no one had a clue as to what was
happening for for over a decade at the
time uh it was it was almost addictive
it was almost uh
a surge of energy and as the show
implies his parents played a large part
in his urges the body is kind of
dissected Lionel knows all about that
he's who kind of sparked Jeff's interest
in the subject remember when you you
should take me to go and find roadkill
and
you'd cut him up oh no no no
you're gonna lay this on me
[Music]
that's not my fault I didn't do this
I was a good dad to Hugh in reality
Dahmer made it clear no one but himself
was to blame and explains quote for
someone who didn't show any emotion or
seemed to care about anything he was
very protective about his parents he had
no inflection in his voice he just said
no one was responsible for what I did
except me to this day I don't know what
started it
and uh the person to blame is sitting
right across from you that's the only
person
not parents not Society not pornography
I mean those are just excuses
foreign